Про розвиток Православної церкви України
напередодні офіційного отримання томоса  ми говоримо
із  митрополитом Київським і всієї України Епіфанієм,
предстоятелем Православної церкви України.
Ваше Блаженство, дякую що знайшли час на інтерв’ю.
Дякую Вам.
Зовсім скоро Ви отримаєте у Константинополі томос.
Вам відомо, які православні  церкви
готові визнати українську православну церкву?
Найперше, отримання томосу від матері-церкви Константинопольської -
це вже є першим кроком у визнанні
іншими помісними православними церквами.
Це є визнанням першої помісної православної церкви.
З часом після отримання томоса ми будемо працювати над тим,
щоб вже інші православні церкви
визнали автокефалію і незалежність нашої української церкви.
Але поки я не можу озвучити,
хто із церков. Звичайно, що найперше визнають церкви грецької традиції.
Ми віримо в це. Але всі говорять
про те, що після офіційного визнання, після вручення томоса,
ми дамо відповідь на питання,
коли ми зможемо Вас визнати як незалежну церкву.
Чи відомо, які церкви, разом у Російською православною церквою не визнають ПЦУ?
Зараз багато говорять і поширюється інформація,
що певні церкви,
які ніби підтримують російську православну церкву,
одразу не визнають автокефалію української церкви.
Я б не хотів називати тих церков.
Бо ми віримо, що правда восторжествує,
і всі церкви - помісні православні церкви -
не одразу, а з часом - визнають нашу автокефалію.
Якщо не помиляюся, сербська церква говорила
про те, що не буде визнавати ПЦУ?
Потрібно розуміти, що загалом
поняття певної церкви не відображається
коментарем одного із архієреїв.
Бо дуже часто ми чуємо певні коментарі
окремих представників тієї чи іншої помісної православної церкви,
які не відображають загалом всієї повноти
тієї чи іншої православної церкви.
Тому якщо говорити суто про Сербську православну церкву,
наскільки мені відомо, що загалом в цієї церкви немає
упередженого ставлення до автокефалії Української православної церкви.
Але є певні окремі особи, архієреї, які коментують
і вважають, що не потрібно визнавати
Сербською православною церквкою автокефалію ПЦУ.
Ви говорили про те, що намагаєтеся робити якомога більше,
аби велика кількість церков визнала ПЦУ.
Що це за заходи? Що саме Ви робите?
Найперше, після мого обрання як предстоятель ПЦУ
я звернувся з відповідними листами,
які носять назву ”Мирних грамот”,
повідомив про те, що відбувся в Києві
історичний Об'єднавчий собор,
на якому мене було обрано предстоятелем
української православної церкви, що я
в майбутньому буду віддано відстоювати
православні позиції, буду опиратися
на канони православної церкви і прошу у них
визнати автокефалію української православної церкви.
Тобто це перший крок новообраного предстоятеля.
Далі буде сформовано вже відповідний відділ
зовнішніх зв’язків церкви, який безпосередньо вестиме
переговори з іншими православними церквами
про визнання нашої автокефалії.
Чи планує приїхати до України патріарх Варфоломій?
Наскільки мені відомо, ще після підписання відповідної угоди
на Фанарі ще попередньо до Об’єднавчого собору
сам патріарх Варфоломій безпосередньо заявив, що він
має бажання знову, вже вдруге,
відвідати православну Україну.
А безпосередньо вже напевно,
спілкуючись вже після отримання томосу,
я отримаю від нього інформацію,
і вже з мого боку буде висловлене запрошення
Його Всесвятості у якнайближчому часі відвідати Україну.
Тобто дату Ви можете обговорювати ось  під час найближчої зустрічі?
Можливо.
Я навіть до кінця не знаю, як буде все відбуватися.
Мені відомо, що вже було запрошення від держави
до Його Всесвятості Варфоломія,
а також після вручення томосу я як предстоятель
незалежної православної українсьої церкви буду також
звертатися із запрошенням до його Всесвятості,
щоб він в найближчий час відвідав Україну.
Петро Порошенко буде їхати з Вами до Константинополя
для отримання Томосу. І він також був присутнім
на багатьох заходах після Собору і після Вашого обрання.
Загалом багато лунає критики про те,
що ПЦУ може стати такою кишеньковою церквою
і що існує завеликий впилив держави на церкву.
Як Ви вважаєте, так це чи ні?
Справді лунає багато критики, але ця критика є несправедливою.
Бо до цього часу ми рухалися майже 30 років
цим складним шляхом, але, на жаль, не могли
об’єднатися і створити єдину помісну церкву.
Тому роль держави в цьому процесі є дуже важливою,
але ми віримо, що в майбутньому
існуватиме така добра симфонія між державою і церквою.
Співпраця повинна існувати, і вона буде існувати.
Але церква ніколи не буде державною.
Як часто Ви телефонуєте в адміністрацію президента?
З яких питань звертаєтеся?
І загалом, як змінилися Ваші стосунки з президентом України
до Вашого обрання і після?
Якщо сказати чесно, то до цього часу
в нас спілкування відбувається з президентом тільки на офіційних заходах
чи зустрічах. А такого контакту
безпосереднього чи вирішення якогось питання - немає.
Суто технічні питання моїх помічників щодо поїздки,
там якихось списків тих людей, які будуть присутні там,
під час богослужіння, бо відповідно буде посиленна охорона.
А якихось таких безспосередніх навіть контактів
чи спілкування у мене немає.
Це свідчить про те, що немає певного втручання
в церковні справи,   і ми як церква вирішуємо питання,
які у нас на порядку денному,
А держава може тільки сприяти і допомагати.
- Тобто телефону президента у Вас немає?
- Немає.
Я не знаю чи в нього є прямий телефон,
не можу цього сказати. Але прямого немає.
Чи є стратегія у ПЦУ,
як працювати із парафіями УПЦ МП?
Моя позиція чітка, яка була висловлена одразу після
Об’єдавчого собору, про те, що двері нашої церкви
відкриті для всіх православних України.
Ми запрошуємо усіх представників, які зараз знаходяться
в лоні Російської правславної церкви,
щоб вони приєдналися до незалежної
української православної церкви.
Якщо говорити про певну стратегію, то вона повинна
будуватися на Євангельських засадах, любові,
миру, порозуміння, братської взаємоповаги.
На практиці як виглядатиме ця співпраця?
Яким чином ПЦУ буде запобігати розколу?
Тому що чимало вірян, з якими ми спілкувалися,
які досі ходять до УПЦ МП,
не визнають Православну церкву України.
Ми розуміємо, що в Україні буде в подальшому існувати Російська православна церква
і буде багато бажаючих залишатися там,
але ми проти цього нічого не маємо.
Всі повинні обирати свій релігійний центр добровільно.
Архієрей з єпархією
чи священник з громадою повинні визначитися.
Якщо вони на загальних зборах вирішують,
що хочуть добровільно долучитися
до новоствореної ПЦУ, відповідно
звертаються до нас, і ми приймаємо їх
вже у нашу структуру єдиної ПЦУ.
З ким простіше вести діалог - зі священиком, з громадою, з єпископами?
Взагалі громада добровільно визначається, на місці.
І ми знаємо, що в Україні є більшість громад,
де переважають ті прихильники української церкви,
які хотіли би приєднатися до
єдиної помісної церкви.
Будуть і противники, але вони в меншості.
Чи зустрічалися Ви з Блаженнішим Святославом Шевчуком,
керівником УГКЦ?
Ми мали зустріч, теплу зустріч з його блаженством
Святославом, ми обговорили подальші кроки
нашої співпраці.
Ми як православна церква не претендуємо
на парафії УГКЦ.
Під час наступної зустрічі ми вже
напишемо певну дорожню карту,
будуть створені відповідні комісії
з двох боків - з нашого боку і з їхнього боку.
ми будемо і в подальшому конструктивно працювати
задля того, щоб в Україні панував міжконфесійний мир.
Коли Ви збираєтесь скликати Помісний собор,
на якому мали б остаточно затвердити статут Церкви
та сформувати керівні органи церкви?
Після цього урочистого акту, який відбудеться
на Фанарі 5-6 січня,
ми, відповідно, почнемо формувати
відповідні керівні органи. Буде створений Священний Синод
нашої церкви, який має право
разом з предстоятелем скликати Помісний православний собор
нашої церкви. Але цей собор відбувся нещодавно,
15 грудня, в стінах Софії Київської,
тому немає такої потреби одразу ж
скликати новий Помісний собор єдиної православної церкви.
Як Ви думаєте, такими посадами в керівних органах церкви
можна заохотити єпископів з УПЦ МП?
Звичайно, хто буде брати
чи приєднуватися до нашої церкви,
також буде брати участь у засідданнях
Архієрейського собору у прийнятті важливих
рішень для розбудови нашої церкви.
Якою Ви уявляєте Православну церкву України через рік?
Зараз важко сказати. Задають багато питань,
виставляють певні хронологічні рамки: а що буде завтра, а що буде через місяць,
через рік. Я вірю, що ми об’єднаємося,
до нас прийде багато тих, які
нині, на жаль, ще сумніваються, до кінця не вірять,
очікують томос, очікують визнаня
цієї дії з боку Константинополя та інших православних церков.
Я вірю в те, що через рік, ми матимемо вже єдину
сильну незалужну українську  помісну православну церкву,
яка буде служити Богові й інтересам нашого народу.
Напередодні Різдва, можливо, скажете українцям привітання?
У ці дні ми повинні стати кращими,
ми повинні допомагати нашим ближнім,
проявляючи любов. Ми повинні згадувати
у своїх молитвах тих, хто перебуває зараз у полоні,
військовополонених. Згадувати і допомагати тим, які втратили
свої домівки у зв’язку з цією
неоголошеною війною на Сході України.
Я вірю, що цей рік буде переможним роком,
і в Україні запанує той довгоочікуваний справедливий мир.
Бо мир в окупації - це теж певною мірою мир,
але це не той мир, якого ми прагнемо. Ми прагнемо миру
в своїй незалежній українській державі,
в якій постане і вже постала і буде утверджена
єдина помісна українська православна церква.
Тому ще раз вітаємо з цим величним святом Різдва Христового.
А також я би хотів запрости всіх православних вірян
міста Києва і, можливо, охочих з усієї України
долучитися до святкового урочистого богослужіння
нагоди Різдва Христового,
яке відбудеться 7 січня о 10:00
в історичному храмі Святої Софії Премудрості Божої,
вперше піля отримання томоса.
- Ваше Блаженство, дякую за інтерв’ю.
- Дякую і Вам.